une passerelle au dessus de l'autoroute
10 des piliers qui poussent un peu
partout de brossard à pointe claire
après une seule année de travaux déjà le
rêve devient réalité dans saint laurent
on construisait ce matin une travée de
40 mètres de la future branche ouest du
rem sept immenses poutres de lancement
sert à transporter puis à poser une à
une chacune de ses pièces de 50 tonnes
seulement dans la partie ouest il y en
aura plus de 4000 pour former la
structure aérienne
longue de 14 km c'est la première fois
au québec on utilise cette technique de
construction qui est très efficace
on parle d'assembler une travilla
environ 2 jours 2 à 3 jours versus qui a
une opération qui pourrait prendre
jusqu'à trois semaines normalement
mieux l'on travaille jour et nuit des
chiffres continue aujourd'hui le budget
du rem 6 milliards 300 millions de
dollars
gordon de yang vient tous les jours
observé l'évolution du chantier à pointe
claire
je suis e-bay itil et pression' et dans
la vitesse et la façon de faire ça va
très bien madame l'avancement votre est
vrai très vite
je suis ingénieur le traité puis je
trouve le techniques sont encore
gérables
ce qui s'en vient cet été est aussi très
intéressant d'un tunnelier qui va être
déployé dans le secteur du technoparc et
là aussi c'est assez inusité de voir ce
tunnel est là qu'un important gabarit
cdpq infra la nouvelle branche de la
caisse de dépôt a beaucoup à gagner leur
m pourrait lui rapporter d'autres gros
contrats
ailleurs sur la planète la reine est
aussi une occasion de développer un
savoir faire qui va pouvoir servir ça a
été déjà comparé à me faire la baie
james
cette branche ouest du rem vers sainte
anne de bellevue l'aéroport montréal
trudeau sera inaugurée en 2023 tout
comme la ligne verte de montagne mais
dès la fin 2021
un premier tronçon du réseau express
métropolitains pourra être utilisé celui
entre brossard et la gare centrale de
montréal
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
pointe claire